Well, say five nice things about me. Quick call, handsome, tan voice, funny, charming, charming, selfless. What else? That's it, I think. We went over five, but we couldn't get to 10. No, you were in a... I feel like I could cut you off. I five, but we couldn't get to ten. Well, no, you ain't, it felt like you were gonna keep going. I feel like I cut you off. I don't think I could possibly get ten. Oh, and an incredible boxer. Welcome to Squirtle.
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. This is smart. Blast.
You know, the one thing I will miss about New York is the prepared meals at the grocery store, because I just, just right before this, I just finished having sushi with the, you know, the spicy tuna. And then, but I always go there and I get like the spaghetti. Like don't you guys love that? You know we go. You know the spicy tuna and then but but I always go there and I get like the spaghetti like don't you guys love that? Like you know we have those out here on the west coast. No, but but not to walk to You know you just walk in you get like a spaghetti and meatballs and you just On your house is beginning meatballs is not sushi. I mean, I'm gonna check it out right now But you check that out. Well, I explained to Sean that if you live near a place that sells pre-packaged food, you can walk to get it. Could you, Sean? You could walk to large
want. If you wanted to, I'm not to believe in you. It's kind of far. Kind of far. Well, I mean, for a guy who doesn't like walking up a flood of stairs, yes. Yes. No, that's not true. He does walk. I will say this about Sean. I like the times when I call him. He's walking. And it's I love to walk. He does. By the way, Amanda says she saw you and all of Sandra knocking down the big hill over here on the other day. That's so adorable. Yeah, will likes a good walk. From the afternoon, I can just see you sort of pushing your laptop aside and saying, reach
for the intercom there in the mansion and you say, Han, what room you in? Are you up for a walk? And then you guys put your angle weights on. You zip into your bag, right? Your sweat bag? I put my sweat bag on and I put my body weights on. And I start climbing that hill. And you know what, the first time I really did that hill
was with you, JB, during the pandemic. And JK, JK. And I remember the first time we did it, and I was like, oh my God, and you were like, you were so good, I was like, fuck, this is so hard. And now I've done it, you know, every time. I know, and well, you live on a hill. You live on a hill.
And so I do try biking, I biked up that one. So you did not. Yeah, that was a whole different thing. That is brutal. I've seen a couple guys do it, and they're barely, they're barely going forward as they go. Yes. Exactly. God bless the 10 speed. But I've seen, I've seen JB, I've seen you over the years, a few times on that hill and usually give me like a scornful look or
whatever, like a sort of a shitty like the, but I just honk and swerve and you try to scare you. Well, it's in the family because Amanda yesterday, I always on this like Tesla comes and say, and the swerving, I'm like, what the fuck? And then it's Amanda waving, you know, yeah, brightly, she's waving brightly. With the Drake just pouring out her window. I just talked to her yesterday. Yeah, end of story.
I were though three hours. Yeah, how's your ears? I love talking to Amanda. She said she's gonna throw me a party when I come home. We got them right, we are. Can I go? I'm like, you, she's going to throw me a party when I come home. We got them right. We are. Can I go? I'm like, you asshole is better at throwing a party.
Are you kidding? Yeah, you're kidding. Isn't it? Isn't it like a week now? JB, you're looking real stripy today. Are we going back on the golf course today? You are. Yeah, I like the shirt, Jay.
It's been a while. I got the shirt while I was visiting with Will out there east. Yeah. I'm going out there to one of a Burbank's finest courses today. And I'm going to enjoy myself. What a life. What a life. I feel like I have something more to say, but maybe I'll think of it while we're talking to our really high level guest here. Oh, nice. Okay. We've bored this person. Huh? We've bored this person. Yeah. Sorry. Sorry, guest. They're day to day. You need to do.
And you know, it's not, it is not the first time he's been exposed to our pain. He's been here before, and I don't want to, I don't want to spoil anything. But it was during a time very, very early on. We didn't really know what we were doing. Things were very, very topical in our interview, so it didn't age well. And there's a few week delay before we put these on, and COVID was, so we ended up not even airing the episode, but he's been, we've got a jack of all trades
and a master of all. Huh? His books have been New York Times bestsellers, his columns and newspapers and websites are instant must reads, his television appearances are a point in TV, and his overall opinions on all things culture, whether it be entertainment,
politics, sports, are unapologetically honest and singular. He has a degree in political science and a masters in print journalism. We three dummies admire him for his already massive success and something we're just trying to figure out, but we love him for his profound work on the Jimmy Kimball show. Please welcome Boston's own William John Simmons III. Bill, we can't out of town. Please. Bill Simmons. Wait a minute. What? Sean still doesn't know who I am. No, I love Bill Simmons. Wait, what happened to the show? We've never aired it because what we talked about was like what was happening that week. And really? Yeah, it was just, it didn't. Yeah, it did one of the first test shows.
Yeah. It wasn't a test, but it wasn't a test. You were one of our big shots right up front along with that shepherd. Oh, so you just squashed it. Oh, I should feel much worse about this. No, it's not even air. It was too, Jason's right, it was too topical. It was too, like, exactly. It was like, what was going on? It was like made. You're not alone. They were caught. I think tapers, same thing happened with Jake Tapper, right? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I just thought you guys didn't like me. And then like, and maybe I said something about those are back. Yeah. We tried to edit it and make it entertaining. It just couldn't make it work. We, we, we love you and revere you in spite of your allegiance
to certain teams. Put it that way here. Certain teams. Like you mean every Boston team? No, not every Boston team. What where's your beef? What don't you like about? I'm not going to I don't want to get into it back and forth to Bill Simmons. He'll crush me. Are you kidding? I don't have the feelings.
I don't have the fire. The only team you have passion for are the other Maple Leafs. Well, you didn't for a while, right? Well, I'm mad. We had a cheap owner and he cost us a Stanley Cup. And I was my 20s and spiteful and I got mad. Right. But now you're back.
Now I'm in a better spot. You're back with the bears? The bears, the brewers. Yeah, they do have the bear more. I mean, the Hershey bears. I thought you became a Hershey bear as a man of the age. Well, we're taping this right now and Mookie Betts is going back to Fenway Park, which was the most traumatic red socks thing that's happened in the last 30 years. Yeah, which was the most traumatic Red Sox thing that's happened.
It's going to be the last 30 years. Yeah, he was our best guy. You guys are both huge baseball fans. Yeah. And did you guys, when Mookiebats came to the Dodgers, was there, did you guys fire some text back and forth? No, I told them. I told all my Dodger fans.
I was like, you guys won the lottery. This guy's amazing. This is the biggest mistake the Red Sox had made in my lifetime. I couldn't get too mad because we won four World Series and I had said before we won the first World Series that I would probably sell my soul to win one World Series. So we won four. Wait, wait, wait.
I thought it was only two. When was there four? So you did sell your soul. I just want to get it. No, we won four. Yeah, I do think I might be going to hell. I think I might have said that drunkenly one night that I would sell my soul.
So it's hard to complain too much, but we had this awesome guy who was great in the community and he's so much fun to watch and they just trade him. How far were the Red Sox from making that deal? Did they have an opportunity to match with the Dodgers' offer them? They got super smart and analytical about baseball players as they hit their 30s, how their production to clients and you're basically paying for past performance, which is true
with like the sluggers. But like the Sean Hayes kind of wary athletic types. Oh boy, that hurts. He's pretty nicely into their 30s. Wary, you know, and Sean is still playing squash and doing whatever he's doing. Look at my, I got my things on. Look at this. He's an oppression rap. He's got his elbow from all of the started.
Camoring the piano, every now and then. Bill, I wanted to ask you, what, I mean, you are sort of a jack of all trades, as Jason said, and you, you, you apply it on lots of different things. But sports is sort of the, was the lead, that was the sort of the cutting edge of, that got you into this world. What was it about you, as a kid, where you like, this is gonna be my milieu? I'm just a sports guy.
I love sports so much, and it's gotta be my life. What was the genesis of you as the ultimate sports guy? Well, it also might have been not having a life. You know, I was the only child and I absolutely love sports. I was all into it and all the Boston teams, my dad had Celtic season tickets, just kind of threw myself into it. And at some point in college, I had a calm in college that front, really from the first week I was in college.
And I was like, I wonder if I can get paid for this. So it was one of those. I just love sports. I remember everything. I have opinions. I have a sense of humor. Can this be something? But it still took me the entire 90s to get there. But you early on decided that you were going to make your journalism come from the perspective of the fan as opposed to sort of trying to stay neutral and just kind of report the facts. Was that shaped by your experience as a Boston fan and that the Celtics were just killing it there and the, what was it? The late 70s or 80s, right? We had a nice run, right? And then the socks were giving you a lot of pain. So did that kind of shape, that's more of like,
I'm a very passionate fan by virtue of the local teams. And so let's do that angle. It was two things. The first one was that the way people wrote about sports back then was very, you know, reportery, like non-fan stuff, right? And it just wasn't the way my friends and I talked. So I never really liked reading that coverage that much because I was like, do these people even like sports?
They just seem like angry old white guys. So it was that. And then the other thing was, because I couldn't get in the club houses, I was writing like a sports column on the internet. I couldn't get press passes for anything. So I really tripled sports column on the internet. I couldn't get press passes for anything. So I really tripled down on, all right. I'm gonna write from the fans perspective. A couple of the writers that I really liked to done that.
Like there was this book, the screenwriter William Goldman had written, called Wait till Next Year, where he wrote all of his parts for about New York sports from a fans perspective. There's Roger Angel and the New Yorker was another one. So I was like, I feel like that's a better lane for this. So I kind of just threw myself into that
and it kind of worked. What was your first moment where you got, not validated, but got on trade. Like where somebody said, okay, you can come in, you can get into the locker room, you can get into the press box, you can have access. What was that moment? Yeah, how do you get into the locker room?
Yeah, that was, so ESPN got my calm in 2001, and I had a little more juice at that point to go to stuff. But at that point, I was like, you know what? Having some distance from this, and writing from the fan side is actually better for me, because that was weaving pop culture and all my stuff. And I was like, I actually think like, this is a better lane.
So for really all the 2000s, I tried to stay away from being kind of too embedded with athletes and getting in there and just kind of being detached. And then in the 2010s, I realized, because I had so much, I don't know, such a high profile at that point. I could talk to just about whoever I wanted.
And I was like, you know what? Now that I'm in my 40s, there's stuff to learn from some of these guys, from some of these coaches. And I really kind of threw myself into just kind of learning more from people who played in coach. Yeah, there was that big transition. You talk about becoming a high profile.
So listen to for those of you that aren't, you you know sports junkies like me and Sean Hayes. You know Bill exploded onto ESPN. He started a podcast of dynasty with with Grant Land and then the ringer. And my podcast was O7, Sean. How about that? It was like me and Mark Maren and like two other dudes. Yeah, I know. I know who you are. I know you've been around.
I know what you do. So tell us about that transition was not gradual. It was pretty not overnight. I don't mean to diminish it or belittle it at all. I don't mean that at all. It was very deserved what happened. Maybe it was just not overnight. I don't mean to diminish it or belittle it at all. I don't mean that at all. It was very deserved what happened. Maybe it was just overdue. But were you comfortable in that transition?
Not only what it did for you publicly and being sort of famous and recognizable? Yeah, that kind of maturing. From ESPN to the next chapter? Well, being on air, like all of a sudden, you were, I remember seeing you on TV. On TV. And I was like, I was like, who is this guy? And I all of a sudden, you were, I remember seeing you on TV. And I was like, I was like, who is this guy?
And I was like, oh, Bill said, oh, that's what Bill Simmons looks like. And listening to you talk, and like, it was just this great, new personality. I remember how disappointed you were at how handsome he was. Yeah, he's handsome too. But there really was definitely like an unapologetics or to use a word again. You didn't really make much of an effort to be some like zippy on-air personality. Like you were just like, I'm just a guy and I got an opinion
and it's backed with knowledge and facts and here we go. It was fun. Yeah, you were fine with just being a plain regular guy, which we really admire. Yeah, we're just small. Yeah, it was actually fun to do those shows because I would just kind of call it like it is. Yeah.
And I think people were surprised initially because it was very like, No, Barclays doing a good job. Studio shows were very, yeah, Barclays could do because he was a hall of famer. But like when the media guys usually came on they were way more careful. I went going backwards, like probably O6,
I made a decision like every single year I want to try to add something and take a swing at something. I don't want to be in the same spot at the end of the next year that I'm in right now, so what can that be? So like in O7, that was when I started 30 for 30, I sent the memo we created a new Connor show. That was when I started writing my basketball book and that was when I started doing my podcast
and then the next year after that, it was like, all right, how can I keep going? How can I keep going? And that led to Grandland in 2011. And then just TV in 2012 and was just each year, what can I do? I don't want to be in the same spot. What I love about it, sorry, and correct me
if I'm wrong, Bill, is that you say you do all these things and you're like, I'm going to do this, I'm going to do this. And it feels like you're at ESPN, then you're at HBO, I think, for a minute. And it's almost like those places just couldn't contain you. You ended up, you're like, well, fuck it, I don't need them, I don't need them. I'll just create my own network. I'll create my own vessel because then I don't have to answer to all that. Is that kind of how it went?
Yeah, I realize I got suspended in 2014. That's fun. From ESPN for, uh, those were dealing all that heroin, right? I mean, yeah, I turned out the age was just not. Yeah, certainly. I don't know. Wait, what did you get suspended for? I said some stuff about the NFL commissioner who was their biggest partner and they got
upset. And when I got suspended, something weird happened. All these people reached out like, hey, when you branch off, I'd love to invest or I'd love to. I said, wait, what's going on? And that really made me start thinking about it pretty seriously. Like, okay, if I left, could I create something? I had some people at Grandland that I really liked working with.
And just over the course of 2015, I was like, all right, what if we could we recreate Grandland as our own thing that we own? We don't have to answer it anybody. Could we really triple down on podcasts? Because we were convinced, you know, he has pended in care about podcasts at all. And we were convinced like, we can probably pay for everything through the podcast revenue. And I never ended up taking money from investors
because I kind of felt like we could pay for everything through my podcast and which is what happened. That's a risky proposition, a little bit nerve wracking, but it's a leap, right? Yeah, I remember explaining it to my wife. And she's like, I trust you, a little bit nerve wracking, but it's a leap, right? Yeah, I remember explaining it to my wife. And she's like, I trust you, but I could see this glimmer and I like, should I go on Raya now
or wait for six months? Raya. Well, before you give us all a layman's lesson on podcasting and where it's going and all that yeah talk a little bit about where this Moxie came from to sort of double down triple down on yourself and and and to be Really proactive in it in an entrepreneurial way because You know dudes that are super big sports fans that like right about it and stuff aren't aren't famous for being business titans
to put it kindly. So where does all that come from? I mean, you're very well educated. You come from, I think your dad was a teacher and your mom was a superintendent. So you're pregnant, yeah. Yeah, so I mean, you're raised by adults and you are one. So is that simply it?
Or do you just have an innate business acumen? You guys are probably going to like this answer. The more I got embedded at ESPN, you start looking around and you're like, wait, I can do that. That guy's kind of terrible. This guy's terrible. Yeah. How did this guy get this job where he decides stuff?
This lady's awful. and you just start going, wait a second, I feel like, I feel like I'm smarter than a lot of these people. Yeah, yeah, it turns out nobody knows what they're doing. But if it's not that, usually I find, if you just get in the door in any sort of industry, sort of the mystery of it that you build up in your mind, just kind of melts away, and that's half the battle.
You think everybody is awesome and all knowing and they're just not. Or that they've got this like well of like secret knowledge that you'll never have access to. You know what I mean? Yeah. And most of the people just got, yeah, they got promoted a couple times
and they kind of can't believe they got to where they got. Like when we did 30 for 30 and people loved it the first time. Is that like 80 for Brady? No. Well, that they were that. That sports documentary series. So we created it and we finished it.
And the person who was in charge of ESPN films, who it changed hands a couple times. And by the time we finished 30 for 30, people loved it. And they were like, all right, so 30 for 30 is done. We're going to call documentary as now ESPN films and do it that way. And they didn like, all right, so 30 for 30 is done. We're gonna call documentaries now, ESPN films and do it that way. And they didn't want to do a second volume. And we were like, we just created a brand.
That's like the hardest thing you could possibly do. So they released like four more documentaries, not called 30 for 30s, they're called ESPN films presents. And everybody was like, you see the new 30 for 30. And we're just sending emails to people. And we're like, we did the new 30 for 30. And we're just sending emails to people and we're like, we did it. Like we did the impossible. We created a brand. Just let's do another volume of 30 for 30. We had to convince them for like nine months. And now the thing's still on 14 years later.
That's amazing. That's so cool. It was so stupid. I can't tell. I would go to, I don't get as mad as I did back in the day, but like in the late, I would just lose my mind. I would send these 2,000 word emails. And I thought it was normal because I worked for Kimmel for 18 months. And you guys know Kimmel, Kimmel, Kimmel's a lunatic.
Like he's just, yeah, Kimmel is like, he will whip off a 700 word email in three seconds at just playing a video game and doing nine other things. So I thought, well, Jimmy's like that too, that's normal. And then you realize, like, oh, Jimmy's also a lunatic. So we're both a lunatic.
Yeah, I'm very similar. Yeah, you guys have who you're shown is, by the way, Shonal, Shonal, answer an email before the person has hit send. He's still a pathically Instagram. And I write Shon a couple of times, I've been like, hey, I'm really sorry, like we're on some sort of like email chain
or business thing, and I'll be like, I'm sorry that I'm not answering yet, but I'm really sorry. Like, we're on some sort of like email chain or business thing and I'll be like, I'm sorry that I'm not answering yet, but I need a minute to think about it. Yeah. Yeah, I've seen Sean's already answered. But you know, it's funny you say that it makes sense that, and I know you and Kim Loa friends, I know you work with them for a little bit,
it does totally make sense that you guys both have this kind of, you're very confident and you're both opinionated, but confident in your opinion and a confident about being right. And generally, I bet you're both right most of the time. And they don't pop off on shit they're wrong about. No. Hold on.
Let's be clear. Kimmel is way worse than I am. He's not confident. He is super stubborn. Yes. And we'll just fight to the death until he just breaks you down and you admit he's right, even though you don't think he's right. But he's smart enough not to dig in on things that he's not smart about.
He'll just back off and it'll be like, I never happen. Yeah. He's like, one of the most frustrating people to argue with because it could be like, we could argue with Celtics. He's like, no, Larry Bird only went to MVP's and I'm like, do I have to get like the basketball on Psychopedia? Like, you definitely want great. No, it was two. And then it was like, no, Larry Bird only went to MVP's and I'm like, huh, do I have to get the basketball on Psychopedia? Like, you definitely went great.
No, it was two. And then it was like, now here it is, it's three. It's like, I told you it was three. And we will be right back. Thank you to Mudwater for supporting the show. As you might know, we've been drinking Mudwater. It's a coffee alternative with four functional mushrooms and with only a fraction of caffeine as a cup of coffee.
You get energy without the jitters or crash of coffee, right? That's why I love it. I love it because it tastes great. I actually love it. I put a little honey in it in the morning and it comes in the powder form. You put it in milk and I add a little honey in there. It's really, really great.
And they sent me this frothother when you stick it in it to stir it. It's kind of like you know those milkshake frathers. You know when you were a kid, and the milkshake machines. But you get your own, and it spins it, and it's really cool. It mixes it really, really well. And it tastes like cacao and chai had a baby.
Each ingredient was added for a purpose. Cacao and chai for a hint of caffeine and hot chocolate-like flavor, lions main to support focus, cordo steps to help support physical performance, and both chaga and rachy to support your immune system. Seriously, guys, the stuff is tasty. Please go get some. So to get your free frothter and free samples of coconut creamer and sweetener, go to mudwater.com- smartless. On that link, you'll get all the samples and froth are for free.
So go to mudwtr.com slash smartless for your free frother. That's mudwtr.com slash smartless. Smartless is sponsored by BetterHelp. So, you know, there was a time in my life when I knew it was good for me, but my brain was getting in the way, like, you know, when I was trying to fall asleep at night, but my mind keeps racing and racing and racing. And, of course, when I wake up in the morning,
either like, or in the middle of the night, just to go to the bathroom, my mind starts racing and racing and racing again. Do you ever feel like your brain is getting in its own way, like me? You know, it takes a lot to calm it down. And what I find helps is therapy. Like, you know, what you should do, what's good for you, but you just can't do it. So what I do to stop the kind of racing thoughts is I utilize therapy, because it always helps me. Therapy helps you figure out what's holding
you back so you can work for yourself instead of against yourself. So if you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists any time for no additional charge. I always, always, always feel better after therapy.
Just had it yesterday. That's why I'm feeling great and I'm talking in a high voice. Make your brain your friend with better help. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartless today to get 10% off your first month. That's betterhelp.help.com slash smartless. Smartless is sponsored by ADT.
ADT self-setup features everything from motion sensors to Google Nest cams with no long-term contracts. How about that? Easily install the ADT self-setup security system at your convenience. No heavy duty tools are needed and if you need help ADT can provide virtual assistance along the way. ADT self-setup grows, moves, and adapts as your needs change. You can add more products at any time and your system easily moves wherever life takes you. It also features Nest Cam's that can tell the difference between a person, an animal, a vehicle,
or with the Nest doorbell, even a package. Plus, when every second counts, you can trust ADT's 24-7 professional monitoring. You can view a video of an alarm event and verify or cancel an alarm with just a tap. When the most trusted name and home security adds the intelligence of Google, you've got a home with no worries. Go to ADT.com today or call 1-800-ADT-ASAP.
Google Nest Cam, Nestor Bell, and Nest aware our trademarks of Google LLC. And now back to the show. And now back to the show. So how did podcasting hit your radar earlier than anybody else, not just listeners, but podcast creators and what was it who whispered in your ear and you got ahead of it and carved away and made it possible for, you know, idiots like us and Dax and I think that I made it possible for your podcast to succeed. Well, it became a medium, you know, it wasn't a medium before you and Mark Mara. Jason, our lawyer has just emailed me and said, take that back.
We'll cut that out later. No, when I started it, it was just because I saw there was this interview link on ESPN.com with the interview with the Celtics GM. And I clicked on it. It was like podcast, it's interview with Danny Engel. I'm like, what the hell is this? So I emailed them and I'm like, can I have one of these? And they were like, okay, and they mailed me this equipment. So I did my first one with an MBA writer, Dave Mark Stein. And the second one was with Corolla. And Corolla came over because I only had one jack in the phone. So he came over and we realized we couldn't do it in the same room.
And he was wandering on my driveway on the phone, doing the podcast with me. So it's like the early days were like crazy rocky. And I was like, these are really fun. I used to have my friends on. And my whole goal was to emulate Mike and the Mad Dog, because I love Mike and the Mad Dog. Sure.
而且他当时正在我家的车道上闲逛，打着电话跟我一起录播客。所以早期的日子简直是疯狂且坎坷。我就觉得，这些真的很有趣。我以前经常请我的朋友们来。我的全部目标就是模仿迈克和疯狗（Mike and the Mad Dog），因为我太喜欢迈克和疯狗了。没错。
And it was like, these guys, I love Mike and the Mad Dog when they would be talking about the Oscars, not like the Rangers would be like, all right, who do you have for best act of dog? And they would be going, I'll be like, this is amazing. What is this? So I would have my friends on,
而且那种感觉就像，这些人，我太喜欢迈克和疯狗谈论奥斯卡时的样子了，他们不会像流浪者队那样，而是会说：“好了，你觉得谁能拿最佳恶犬奖？”然后他们就会开始争论，我就想：这太棒了！这是什么神仙节目？所以我就会请我的朋友们来，
and just like people that I thought I would have good chemistry with. And then around 09, I'd had it for about two years. And I remember Seth Meyers text, he emailed me about it. And he was like, yeah, Jacko was my buddy, Jacko's. Yeah, Jacko was feeling it today. It was so funny. And I'm like, you listen, like I had no idea
找那些我觉得能擦出不错火花的人。然后在09年左右，这个节目我已经做了大约两年。我记得赛斯·梅耶斯（Seth Meyers）发短信，他给我发邮件提到了这事。他说，哦，杰科是我的哥们儿，杰科。对，杰科今天状态极佳。太搞笑了。然后我说，你居然会听？因为我根本不知道
of people were listening because they didn't tell me the numbers. And I was like, you want to come on? So in 2009, I started just having these celebrities on. And I was like the first podcast for, I would say like 50 celebrities. And all of them thought it was a, it was like a first date with somebody who were like, that was amazing.
有没有人在听，因为他们不告诉我收听数据。我就问：你愿意来上节目吗？所以在2009年，我开始邀请这些名人来做客。可以说，对于大概50位名人来说，我是他们的第一个播客访谈。他们所有人都觉得这就像是跟某人的第一次约会，他们会觉得：太棒了。
And now it's like all these, every celebrity's been on what? 50 podcasts, There's nothing special about it anymore. But it was really fun to grab people. So by like 2009, 2010, people were mentioning it to me on the street. They weren't mentioning, they were mentioning my column, but then some people were like, Hey man, love the podcast. I was like, Oh, and it just felt like it was building. It's also a great way for celebrities to be, to have an extended conversation with an interviewer
而现在的情况是，所有这些名人，哪个没上过50个播客？这已经没什么特别的了。但当时能拉到人来聊确实非常有趣。所以在2009、2010年左右，人们开始在街上对我提起它。他们不再提我的专栏，而是有些人会说：“嘿，哥们儿，很喜欢你的播客。”我当时就想：哦？感觉节目真的在一步步做大。这也是名人与采访者、
or journalist or whatever, and not run the risk of having a headline. You know, Cherry picked out of there for some sensational reviews. Like a cock can know. Yeah, it's all verbatim. And I remember talking to you about it, Jason, because you were like, we were talking about a frustrating the talk show circuit is. Yeah, especially when all verbatim. Well, I remember talking to you about it, Jason, because you were like, we were talking about
记者或任何人进行深入交流的绝佳方式，不用冒着被断章取义做成耸人听闻的头条新闻的风险。你知道，有些标题党专门挑刺。就像柯南可能知道的那样。是的，全部都是逐字实录。我记得跟你聊过这个，杰森，因为你当时在讨论……我们当时在谈论脱口秀节目那一套流程有多让人沮丧。是的，尤其是当所有内容都逐字……哦，我记得跟你聊过这个，杰森，因为你当时在讨论
a frustrating the talk show circuit is. Yeah, especially when you come out and you do like, well, Kimmel's like, but you do like, you're on a talk show for 10 minutes, right? And you do the pre-interview and you come out and you hit your three things and you have a little back and forth. And I think for the celebrities, the podcast was just
脱口秀节目那一套流程有多让人沮丧。是的，尤其是当你出来做节目时，吉米（Kimmel）那种，但你做的时候，你上一个10分钟的脱口秀，对吧？然后你做了前期采访，接着你走出来，讲完你那三件事，然后进行一小段互动。我觉得对名人们来说，播客这种形式要
such a more fun format, because it was like, this is what I really am. Yeah, the podcast was just such a more fun format because it was like this is a really bad thing. You're hanging out. For sure. So that was a big win for everybody. Bill, tell me, sorry, just go back again. So your parents were teachers. What did they think?
有趣得多，因为他们觉得：这才是真实的我。是的，播客这种形式真的是有趣太多了，因为这就感觉像是一件非常糟糕的事。你们就是在闲逛。肯定的。所以这对每个人来说都是巨大的成功。比尔，告诉我，抱歉，我们再回到刚才的话题。你的父母都是老师。他们是怎么想的？
What did you say to them when you graduated college? You're like, all right, I'm just going to go into the sports thing. Were they like great? Were they expecting you to become a teacher? Did they want you to become a lawyer? No, I think they was like 50, 50 for them, I was gonna be able to have a steady job. I don't kinda think I was thinking of a club
你大学毕业时对他们说了什么？你是不是说：“好吧，我要去搞体育这行了。”他们觉得很棒吗？他们是期望你当老师，还是想让你当律师？不，我觉得对他们来说是一半一半，他们觉得我能找到一份稳定的工作就行。我当时其实在考虑读一个
of a master's degree in print journalism. Well, that was a thing. I got a mess. My senior year, my dad was like, hey, what are you gonna do next year? I was like, I don't know. And he's like, you should, you maybe keep going on the sports round thing. Now, you're right. And I was like, I don't know. And he's like, you should maybe keep going
平面新闻学硕士学位。对，就是这么回事。我大四的时候，我爸问我：“嘿，你明年打算做什么？”我说：“我不知道。”他说：“你应该，也许你可以继续在体育圈里混。”现在看来，你是对的。然后我说：“我不知道。”接着他说：“你应该，也许可以继续
on the sports round thing. You're right. And I just like, the last minute applied to three journalism schools and got into a goal. So he encouraged you. Yeah, it was more like, what are you doing next year and just kind of staring vacantly back with no answer. But then I went to journalism school
在体育圈里混。”现在看来，你是对的。然后我临时申请了三所新闻学院，结果考上了一所。所以是他鼓励了你？对，与其说鼓励，不如说他当时问我“你明年打算做什么”，而我只是两眼空洞地看着他，答不上来。后来我上了新闻学院，
and it didn't work out right away. Like I worked at the Boston Herald for three years and did grumbourk and Chinese food orders and covered high school sports. And by 96, I was out. I was bartending. So did you play sports as a kid and then did you not want to go into professional sports
但并没有立刻顺风顺水。比如我在《波士顿先驱报》干了三年，做着底层杂务、帮大家订中餐外卖，还报道高中体育。到了96年，我彻底失业了。我在当酒保。所以你小时候也做过运动，然后你是不想走上职业运动员这条路吗，
like playing them? I was like high school level best. Yeah. And what's for that? Yeah, what was your sport? Basketball was like high school level best. Yeah. In what's your sport? Basketball. Basketball is my favorite. Yeah. Oh my God.
比如亲自去打比赛？我的水平大概也就是高中校队最好。就是这样。那你的项目是？篮球水平大概也就是高中校队最好。对。那你的项目是什么？篮球。篮球是我的最爱。对。哦天哪！
I still played tennis. I had to retire from basketball ten years ago because we're all old people. Or did you roll, did you roll an ankle too many times? Yeah. I remember speaking to Northby ex-Surgian once in New York and she was just basically like, yeah, like nine out of 10 injuries of dudes over 30 or from basketball. Yeah. And now it's like pickleball on basketball.
我到现在还在打网球。我十年前不得不从篮球界“退休”了，因为我们都老了。或者说你是不是脚踝扭了太多次？对。我记得有一次在纽约跟北鼻的前外科医生聊过，她基本上就直说：“没错，30岁以上老爷们儿的伤病，十分之九都是打篮球造成的。”现在则是匹克球和篮球并列了。
Yeah, pickleball. Yeah, I played basketball when I was a kid and I was like, you know, we'd run down to one end of the court and I'd be like, and then they'd get the ball the rebound and I'm like, wait, we gotta go all the way back. We just, we gotta go all the way back to the other side. I don't, I don't understand. And why do I, can't we just play half the court?
对，匹克球。对，我小时候打过篮球，当时的感觉就是，你知道的，我们一路跑到球场的另一端，然后我就想……接着他们抢到了球、拿到了篮板，我就想：等等，我们还得全场跑回去吗？我们得一路跑回另一边去？我搞不懂，我真的搞不懂。为什么我们就不能只打半场？
I didn't understand it. I was too much for me. So so basketball was your, your main sport. You played baseball too, I imagine, a little bit when you were kid. I played everything until high school. I just played basketball. I love basketball the most though, because we, we had the season tickets.
我完全无法理解。这对我来说运动量太大了。所以篮球是你的主要运动项目。我想你小时候也打过一点棒球吧？我什么都玩，直到上了高中，我才只打篮球。不过我最喜欢的还是篮球，因为我们有赛季套票。
We were like front and center for the whole Larry Bird era. So I just understood it the most. Did you grew up in Boston, Boston, or did you grew up? Yeah, I grew up in Brookwine. And my parents got divorced, which is why I have a sense of humor. Yeah, exactly. My mom moved to Connecticut,
整个拉里·伯德（Larry Bird）时代，我们的座位都在正中央、最前排。所以我对篮球的理解最深。你在波士顿长大的吗？波士顿市区，还是其他地方？对，我在布鲁克莱恩（Brookline）长大。我的父母离婚了，这就是为什么我很有幽默感。对，没错。我妈妈搬到了康涅狄格州，
and eventually I moved to live with my mom for high school. Okay. And I got divorced at a tough time for you too. 13, I think it was. No, I was nine. Oh, you had the red socks. Yeah, don't read Wikipedia. The red socks last to the Yankees in 1978 playoff game,
后来为了上高中，我也搬去跟妈妈一起住。好的。你父母离婚时对你来说也是个艰难的时期吧？大概13岁吧，我想。不，我当时九岁。哦，正好赶上红袜队……对，别看维基百科。红袜队在1978年的季后赛中输给了洋基队，
which was the most dramatic sports loss ever. Bruins lost to the Canadians, and my parents got separated all in the span of six months. So, and end glasses. Wow. It was tough. Wait, was that 78? Did you say 78?
那是史上最戏剧性的体育失利。棕熊队输给了加拿大人队，而我父母也在短短六个月内分居了。所以，再加上还戴上了眼镜。哇。那段日子真难熬。等等，那是78年吗？你刚才说是78年？
78 and early 70. Yeah, because the leaves, the leaves lost. They were swept by the Canadians before that. But the Canadians, yeah, they just, so you were both on the edge of a few buildings that year. I was, it was tough. Well, he's had, I mean, the leaf thing is, it's so tough. One of the most traumatic professional sports relationships that anyone has. Oh, I, nothing, nothing good happens with the brand in chanahan's going to bring it all back.
78年和70年代初。对，因为枫叶队，枫叶队输了。在此之前他们被加拿大人队横扫了。但加拿大人队……对，所以那一年你们就像是站在好几栋大楼的边缘摇摇欲坠。我是的，那段日子太难了。你看，枫叶队这事，真的是太难了。这是任何人可能拥有的、最具创伤性的职业体育主队情结之一。哦，我……跟枫叶队在一起永远不会有什么好结果，不过香纳汉（Shanahan）会把这一切都带回正轨的。
Shannys, Shannys are my love. He's the best. He's the best dude. I actually just played golf with Shannys and Mike from Mike and the mad dog a couple of years. Yeah. Will, did you ever get tempted by the Kings just like doing a full hockey divorce and just second wife with the Kings? I could I mean I go to Kings games when I'm here and I'll you know sometimes with the kids and stuff just for fun but I'm just such a huge hockey fan but the Leafs are just my team. They're just it for me and they always have been in this. It's been hilarious that people will divorce human beings but not their teams. Like if Will is like I'm I'm now a Kings fan. I'm like, that's horrible.
香尼，香尼是我的最爱。他太棒了。他绝对是个极品好人。其实就在几年前，我还和香尼以及来自“迈克和疯狗”的迈克一起打过高尔夫。对。威尔，你有没有想过彻底跟枫叶队做个“曲棍球式离婚”，把国王队（Kings）当作你的第二春？我可以……我的意思是，我在这里的时候会去看国王队的比赛，你知道的，有时会和孩子们一起去，纯粹为了好玩。但我实在是个太狂热的曲棍球迷了，而枫叶队才是我的主队。他们对我的意义非凡，一直都是如此，而且这……
You broke up with the Maple Leafs. That's the worst thing I ever heard. You know what, if it's a relationship, it's fine. You know it's funny. So when I was with Shani a couple of weeks ago, he goes, he's like, I think he heard on the podcast or somewhere he goes, so I heard you say, because I've become like in the last 10, 12 years,
人们会跟人类伴侣离婚，但却不会跟自己的主队离婚，这不是很搞笑吗？如果威尔突然说：“我现在是国王队球迷了。”我会觉得：这太可怕了。
a massive soccer fan and a big Liverpool supporter through my friend and I just, I love taught them. Get him. Do you, are you taught them, fan? It lasted three years until my kids started playing sports every Saturday and that's for me. It's tough. Yeah, it was too hard.
你竟然跟多伦多枫叶队分手了？这是我听过最离谱的事。你知道吗，如果把它当成一段恋爱关系来看，其实也还好。你知道最逗的是什么吗？几周前我跟香尼在一起时，他说……他好像是在播客还是什么地方听说了这事，他说：“我听说你……”因为在过去这10到12年里，我变成了一个狂热的足球迷，通过我的朋友成了一个坚定的利物浦拥趸，我太喜欢他们了。抓到你了。你是个热刺球迷吗？
But it's, yeah, so I'm up at 4 30 in the morning watching games and stuff. And I'll watch, I'll watch, I'll watch Punez Legal, I'll watch LaLiga, I'll watch anything, Champions League forget it. Get me so hot. So I so watching it. I got it. And I guess I'd sort of said off hand that like it's that watching Liverpool and watching Sockers become almost
这种状态持续了三年，直到我的孩子们开始在每个星期六都有体育比赛要踢，这就很难办了。对，太难了。是的，所以我会早晨4点半起来看比赛什么的。我会看……我会看西甲、西乙，什么都看，至于欧冠？那更是绝不放过。让我兴奋得不行。所以我太爱看比赛了。我懂了。而且我之前随口说过，看利物浦和看足球比赛几乎
is almost taken over hockey. And he looked at me with such disappointment. He's like, is that true? Is that true that you love? And I go, first of all, relax. Yeah. I'll be so sad of that. But I do, it has helped to kind of mitigate my frustration or disappointment by watching that because I'm so invested in the lease. I live and die by. And the, you know, so I've gotten into, and football has been a really great soccer
快要取代曲棍球了。他当时看着我的眼神充满了失望。他说：“这是真的吗？你真的最爱足球吗？”我说：“首先，放松点。”听到这话我真为他难过。不过确实，看球在某种程度上帮我缓解了因为对枫叶队倾注太多心血而产生的沮丧或失望情绪。我对枫叶队爱恨交织，生死相随。而且，你知道的，所以我也开始关注……足球已经成为了一个非常棒的、
has become a really great sort of antidote to that. And so I can have some, I can have some highs. Better attention span sport too. It's two hours. There's a half time. It's fantastic. It just flies through and you're done. It's perfect.
缓解这种情绪的绝佳解药。这样我能体验到一些高光时刻。这也是一项注意力持续时间更友好的运动。只要两个小时，中场休息一下，比赛就结束了。简直太棒了。时间一晃就过去，比赛就完了。太完美了。
And once I got into an understanding who the people were and what the stories were behind it is super interesting and champion and things and so on. But and I'll watch virtually any sport, which makes me like I ended up watching, you know, the ashes, the cricket, I'll watch 2020 cricket T20 like I'll watch and I think like is there anything I won't watch that it's not a sport. When you watch, is there any sport you won't watch? Not a sport. Well, okay.
一旦我开始投入并理解了这些球员都是谁、背后的故事是什么，就会觉得超级有趣，比如欧冠之类的各种赛事。而且基本上任何运动我都看，这导致我最后甚至会去看……你知道的，比如板球对抗赛（The Ashes），20板球、T20板球我都会看。我就在想，有什么运动是我不看的吗？只要它算是运动。当你看比赛时，有没有哪项运动是你绝对不看的？不算运动的。好吧。
It's a game. It's not. It's a game. A great is there any so is golf a sport then game game baseball is a game, not a sport. Well, okay, it's a game. It's not. It's a game. Is there any. Is golf a sport then game? Game. Baseball is a game, not a sport. Yeah, I guess golf is a game, but the, but the, but the top guys are athletes. True.
那是个游戏，它不是。那是个游戏。那么高尔夫算是一项运动吗？游戏。游戏。棒球是个游戏，不是运动。好吧，算是个游戏，但……但最顶尖的那些人是运动员。没错。
Yeah, but have you seen the bodies on the red socks? No, no, no, no, golf. I'm saying golf. I'm saying golf. Is there a sport you won't watch? Sorry, that was my, my big, long lead. Is there a sport I won't watch? Sorry, that was my big long lead. Is there a sport I won't watch? Yeah, that you don't enjoy watching. I don't get auto racing and like there's this
对，但是你见过红袜队球员的身材吗？不不不，我说的是高尔夫。我是说高尔夫。有没有哪项运动是你绝对不看的？抱歉，我刚才铺垫了超级长的一段。有没有哪项运动是我绝对不看的？抱歉，我刚才铺垫了超级长的一段。有没有哪项运动是我绝对不看的？对，就是你觉得不好看、不享受的运动。我不理解赛车运动，虽然现在有一股F1复兴的热潮，我也试着去深入了解过，但我实在无法理解围着一个圈开车有什么意思，就是绕圈跑。我真的不懂。
step one resurgence and I gave it a kick a kick drive and I just get driving around the circle. It's just going in laps. I don't get it. Well, the road courses I get, but circles, you'll come to Formula One with me, you'll get it. Come with me. Listen, you're the 100th person. It's like, no, no, you'll get it. You just, but it's starting to feel like Scientology a little bit. We're like, you don't understand.
好吧，街道赛我还能理解，但绕圈跑……你下次跟我一起去看F1，你就懂了。跟我去吧。听着，你已经是第一百个这么对我说的人了。他们总说：“不，不，你去看了就懂了。”但这听起来越来越有点像山达基教（Scientology）了，对方会说：“你不懂，你得成为米斯卡维奇（Miscavige）才能懂。等你到了那个时候自然就懂了。”结果只是去和他们吃个早午餐。我觉得吧……我不知道我能不能哪怕一秒钟爱上这玩意儿。这比喻太糟糕了。
You've got to be miscavage. You'll get it when you need it. Just have brunch with them. It's like, I don't know. It doesn't take. I don't know if I love that for a second. That's a terrible. So wait, so this is a perfect opportunity.
所以等等，这绝对是一个绝佳的机会。
I bet. And this is going to be a long question. So wait, so this is a perfect opportunity. I've asked. And this is going to be a long question. Just hang in there because I was like, should I ask it? Should I not ask it? I'm going to ask it. How do you go make a sandwich? Yeah, I'm going to pee. I've heard you're a long question shot.
我敢打赌。而且接下来会是一个很长的问题。所以等等，这绝对是一个绝佳的机会。我一直在问。而且这会是一个很长的问题，大家请耐心听着，因为我之前一直在纠结：我该问吗？我不该问吗？不管了，我还是要问。你平时怎么做三明治？对，我要去嘘嘘。我听说你经常问很长的问题。
I'm excited. They're not. Okay, so it's to the three of you guys. So and this is a perfect opportunity to ask this and I wasn't going to ask it. But here we go. It's already too long. No, no, hang on. All the qualifiers. No, so I...
我很期待。其实并不长。好吧，这个问题是抛给你们三个人的。所以，这绝对是一个提问的绝佳机会，我本来不打算问的，但话到嘴边了。好吧，问题已经太长了。不，不，等等。前面铺垫了那么多。不，所以……
Just a big qualifier guy with this question. So what is the psychology behind loving sports so much? Okay, so wait. So like, you know, in movies, theater, TV, whatever it is, you're watching a story, you're emotionally invested, you're watching the beginning, middle, and end of something. In sports, I get it. There is a beginning and end because who's going to win and then they win.
这个人抛出问题前总是要加一堆冗长的铺垫。所以，人们如此热爱体育，这背后的心理机制到底是什么？好吧，等等。比如说，在电影、戏剧、电视剧或者任何艺术形式里，你在看一个故事，你投入了情感，你在观看一件事物的开始、发展和结束。在体育里，我懂，它也有开始和结束，因为总会分出谁赢了，然后他们就赢了。
Okay, sure. But what is this psychology about loving it? So like, what are you rooting for other than a team that you don't have in your personal connection to? Yeah, you go first. I'll go first. Yeah, for me, it's just simply, and it's heightened by the Olympics because it's only every four
好吧，当然。但这种对体育的热爱，其背后的心理到底是什么？除了那些你没有个人现实联系的主队之外，你到底在为主队加油个什么劲？行，你先说。我先来。对，对我来说，非常简单，而且奥运会让这种感觉更加强烈，因为奥运会四年才一次。
years. It's the televised live moment of somebody putting everything they've got on the line and it's a binary result of success or failure. And I get to see this person reach for excellence and let's see what the best they can do is going to yield. And that's a really exciting thing to me. And it's see what the best they can do is gonna yield. And that's a really exciting thing to me. And it's not, and it's unwritten. Yeah.
那是通过电视直播呈现的瞬间，某个人把自己拥有的一切都押在上面，最后得到的是一个二元化的结果：成功或失败。我能看到这个人对卓越的追求，并看看他们能做到的极限最终会带来什么成果。这对我来说是一件非常激动人心的事。去看看他们所能做到的极限最终会带来怎样的结果。这对我来说是一件非常刺激的事。而且，它不是剧本写好的。对。
I get that. I would say for me, it's not dissimilar. And as I explained my sort of my appreciation of soccer was came from understanding the stories and the people behind it. What's like, you told me that well. So once I can get into like like, this guy came over here, and for me, it's not necessarily binary
我懂你的意思。对我来说，其实也差不多。正如我之前解释的，我对足球的欣赏来自于理解背后的故事和人物。就像你之前对我说的那样。所以一旦我能沉浸进去，比如：这个球员是从这里来的……对我来说，结果不一定非黑即白，
because there is victory sometimes in people in failure when they don't actually get it, but they try really hard, I like that part. Yeah, but the story is like, you told me that to a long time ago, you're like, you should just try to watch the stories of the people. So I'm watching, I'm like,
因为有时候人们即使失败了，也能展现出一种胜利感——当他们没有真正赢得比赛，但他们拼尽了全力，我喜欢这部分。对，但故事的本质就像你很久以前对我说的那样，你当时说：“你应该试着去了解人物背后的故事。”所以我看着看着就想：
well, this is a date line episode. Like, I could just watch, you know, I could learn about these people without watching them kick a ball around for two hours. Sure. You know what I'm saying? So. But then there is a moment,
这简直就是一集《日界线》（Dateline）罪案纪实节目啊！我完全可以去了解这些人的生平，而不必非得看他们在一块场地上踢两个小时的球。对吧？你懂我的意思吧？所以。但话又说回来，
there is an actual venue for them to go and try to do that. You see the story behind it. So like for instance, if you watch like one of these great soccer documentaries, and you see the importance of the team to the town and to the fans you see. And then you see these players and these guys
这里有一个真正的竞技场，让他们去尝试、去拼搏。你能看到这一切背后的故事。所以，举个例子，如果你看了一部那些伟大的足球纪录片，你就会看到这支球队对整个小镇、对球迷的重要意义。然后你看到了这些球员，看到这些小伙子们
in their town and what it means. And then the players who come in and they're trying to do it and they're trying to do it not just to win, but they understand the cultural impact that they have. They feel it, they know it. And watching them go through that is super compelling to me. Yeah, I kind of also, but on the other side, I went to a daughter's game with Jason a couple years ago. And we're sitting there and I was like. Yeah, I get it. And also, but on the other side, I went to a Daughter's game with Jason a couple years ago, and we're
在他们的小镇里生活，以及这一切对他们的意义。接着是那些加盟球队的球员，他们努力奋斗，不仅为了赢球，还因为他们理解自己所肩负的文化影响力。他们能感受到，他们心知肚明。看着他们经历这一切，对我来说超级有吸引力。对，我也……不过从另一个角度来看，几年前我和杰森一起去看了道奇队（Dodgers）的比赛。我们坐在那儿，我就想……
sitting there. And I was like, I kind of get it. I get like the atmosphere. It's like watching this old house on a Sunday. You're like, Oh, this is very relaxed. This is so well. You know what I mean? I get almost there. They'll get them back on track. But if Sean in the same way that like for me, I can't go, I can't get into musicals. Right. And I there. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, that it is sort of adjacent to what I do as a profession. And yet I still can't, it's just not for me. It doesn't speak to me.
对，我懂了。而且从另一个角度来看，几年前我和杰森一起去看了道奇队的一场比赛，当时我们正坐在那儿，我就觉得：我好像有点懂了。我懂那种氛围了。这感觉就像在星期天看一档老房子翻新节目一样。你就会觉得：哦，这太轻松了。这感觉真好。你知道我的意思吗？我几乎快要理解了。不过他们会重回正轨的。但如果香尼也是这样的话，对我来说，我就无法……我无法融入音乐剧。没错，而且我……不不不不不……这明明与我的职业息息相关。然而我依然无法接受，这实在不适合我。它无法引起我的共鸣。
And for whatever reason sports does in that way. And Bill, you probably have a much more insight. I just think it's almost like a DNA thing. It's got to hit you before like age six. And I see it with a couple of my friends kids. I have like my friend Nathan's kid, just like I could tell when he was six. I was like, oh, he's gonna be one of those guys. He's going to be really. And now he is. He's like 14 and
不管出于什么原因，体育就能做到这一点。比尔，你可能更有深刻的见解。我只是觉得这几乎就像是一种DNA层面的东西。它必须在你6岁之前就击中你的心。我从一些朋友的孩子身上看到了这一点。我朋友南森的孩子，我能看出他6岁时……我就想：哦，这小子以后绝对是那类狂热球迷。他一定会……现在他真的成了。他大概14岁了，
he's one of those guys. Yeah. Like like I was obviously I'm from Chicago when the Cubs won finally 45, six years ago. I remember when that was. I was crying because I was like, oh my God. They haven't won in so much to the city. 200 years. I'm from Chicago. Like that was incredible. Yeah. That's it. Yeah. But but and and I'm a huge football fan. I just need a reason to watch like I need to bet or something. When I when I was growing up in Boston the 70s is but the cold weather city is you know it's pretty miserable for like four or five months. It has this too. I don't know. Will knows. But you know the sports teams take this outside as importance of just like the kind of,
绝对就是那种资深球迷。对……就像我一样，显然我是芝加哥人，45、6年前小熊队（Cubs）终于夺冠的时候。我还记得那是怎么回事。当时我都哭了，因为我想：天哪！他们200年没夺过冠了，这对整个城市来说意义重大。我是芝加哥人。那感觉太不可思议了。对，就是这样。但……而且我是个超级美式橄榄球迷，我只是需要一个看球的理由，比如我需要下注或者干点别的。我在70年代的波士顿长大，那是个寒冷的城市，你知道的，一年里有四五个月天气非常悲惨。多伦多也是这样，我不知道，威尔肯定懂。但你知道，当地体育球队的胜负被赋予了极其重要的意义，某种程度上，
whatever the teams are doing, kind of sets the mood of the city. And when Bird showed up for the Celtics in 1979, and we realized pretty quickly, this is one of the most special athletes in any sport and we get to go on this ride with him for the next 10, 12 years. That's when it goes to all their level.
无论球队表现如何，都会直接定下整座城市的基调。当伯德在1979年为凯尔特人队登场时，我们很快就意识到：这是任何运动中最特别的运动员之一，我们能和他在未来10到12年里一起经历这段征程。那一刻，一切都升华到了一个全新的高度。
Like Cleveland had that with LeBron and the Lakers had that with Kobe and, you know, you just kind of hit the lottery when it happens and that's going to make everyone care more. Bill, you know, I remember distinctly thinking this at the time and Sean, again, this kind of goes to the way it makes you feel. I remember when Tiger starting in sort of 99 through 2008, really up to the 2008 US Open, in that time, he did something that was so spectacular. And I remember thinking, there are people who didn't like him,
就像克利夫兰拥有勒布朗（LeBron）时那样，湖人拥有科比（Kobe）时也是如此。这种事发生时，你就像是中了彩票，这会让每个人都加倍投入。比尔，你知道的，我当时对这一点有非常清晰的想法，而且香尼，这又回到了体育带给你的那种奇妙感受上。我记得当泰格·伍兹（Tiger）从99年开始一直到2008年，特别是到2008年美国公开赛期间，在那段时间里，他做了一些极其壮观的事情。我当时就在想——虽然有些人不喜欢他——
I remember thinking, I hope we all appreciate how incredible it is what this guy is doing. It was so, and that we're alive during it. And we're alive, and we get to watch it in real time. Yeah, that is cool. That is cool. I thought you were about Jason with those arcs. Yeah, I agree. Oh my God. I'm a member of this species. And then we get to with the slow blink with the slow blink that McConaughey pointed out. You know, McConaughey pointed out that Jason's got the best slow blink. He's a slow blink call. To be honest. I'm not sure
但我当时想的是：我希望我们所有人都能意识到，这家伙正在做的事情是多么的不可思议。那真是太震撼了，我们居然能亲历那个时代。我们不仅活着，还能实时见证这一切。对，那真的很酷。那真的很酷。我以为你是在说杰森的那些眼神转换呢。对，我同意。哦天哪。我是这个物种的成员。然后我们迎来了马修·麦康纳（McConaughey）指出的那个“慢眨眼”。你知道，麦康纳指出杰森拥有最棒的慢眨眼。他是个慢眨眼达人。说实话，我不太确定
what that compliment was, but I took it. I loved it. I have thought about it every moment. I looked at myself in the mirror yesterday. I was like, I tried to do a slow blink and I realized, wait, I can't see what I'm doing. So I'm not sure what he's talking about. That's good. That's good. Hey, Bill, I don't even mean to back you into anything controversial, so feel free to pull the rip cord if it is. But online sports betting that is now sort of really all over the place on television and online and whatnot. How do you feel about, are you worried about your average sports viewer, especially because
那到底是不是句夸奖，但我全盘接受了。我爱死这个评价了。我之后每时每刻都在琢磨这事。昨天我还对着镜子照了照，心想：我来试着做个慢眨眼。结果我发现，等等，我自己根本看不见自己是怎么眨眼的。所以我根本不知道他在说什么。好吧，好吧。嘿，比尔，我可不是想把你逼进任何有争议的话题里，所以如果这是个雷区，你随时可以拉紧急逃生绳。但是现在电视上、网络上到处都是在线体育博彩，随处可见。你对此有什么看法？你担心你的普通体育观众吗？尤其是因为
like when you start talking about the six year old, you know, like pretty soon, he's gonna have a phone and he's gonna have like, a, you know, an allowance every week. And he's gonna be able to make little bets prompted by the on air announcers saying, hey, listen, if you're thinking this might be a field goal versus a touchdown, you can bet right now.
就像你刚才说的那个6岁的小孩，（你想想）要不了多久，他就会有一部手机，每周还会有一笔零花钱。然后他就能通过电视转播里解说员的提示下注，解说员会说：“嘿，听着，如果你觉得这次进攻是会踢任意球还是达阵，你现在就可以下注。”
Like people are gonna get hurt and I'm wondering how you feel about that being in the space right now. Well, the way the apps are set up, it's impossible for any non-adult to just start a gambling account. Like my son is a sophomore in high school. He can't gamble because he's not a lad. So they have a lot of checks and balances with that. I just think this is where it's been going. Yeah. Really for the last 20 years.
这种事会害惨很多人的，我想知道你身处这个行业，对此有什么感受？好吧，从这些博彩应用程序的设置方式来看，任何未成年人都绝对不可能随随便便就开通一个赌博账户。比如我儿子现在是高中二年级。他根本不能赌博，因为他还没成年。所以平台设置了大量的审核和平衡机制。我只是觉得，体育博彩的发展方向本该如此。过去20年来其实一直都在朝这个方向演变。
Like I remember when I my first couple of years at ESPN.com gambling was like a big part of the way my friends and I talked about sports and they wouldn't even let me write a gambling column the first year in 2001 with the spreads. But the honor and answers sort of encouraging that. and one with the spreads. But the honor and answers sort of encouraging that. Do you feel like that's on the same side of the line? Or not? I don't know if they're encouraging it as much as it's part of the dialogue of sports now to put in the-
比如我记得我在ESPN.com工作的头几年，博彩其实就是我和朋友们聊体育时非常重要的一部分。2001年我刚去的时候，他们甚至都不让我写带有盘口的博彩专栏。但现在转播解说员却在某种程度上鼓励这种行为。2001年的时候，写盘口甚至都不被允许。但现在的转播解说员却在某种程度上鼓励这种行为。你觉得这和过去是同一性质吗？还是说有区别？我不知道这算不算鼓励，倒不如说这已经成了现代体育对话的一部分……
Well, but they're promoting it. And I think the network is a participant in that action. I could be wrong with that. Well, ESPN just did a deal. ESPN bet they're calling it. I mean, yeah. I think they all kind of see where it's going. They're doing that with pin. Yeah, they, they, but, but Bill, you, again, correct me if I'm wrong. You know, the NFL has, and all sports, but certainly the NFL always posted the odds and the newspaper for as long as it was always about that.
但他们确实在推广它。我觉得电视网本身就是这种行为的参与者。也许我的看法不对。好吧，ESPN刚刚做了一笔大交易，他们把它叫做“ESPN博彩”（ESPN Bet）。我的意思是，对吧。我觉得他们都看清了这个行业的发展趋势，他们正在通过Penn（娱乐公司）来做这件事。对，他们……但比尔，我说的如果有错请纠正我。你知道，NFL以及所有体育联盟，当然尤其是NFL，一直在报纸上公布赔率，这事儿历来如此，一直都跟这个脱不了干系。
Right. Oh, they want it. It's just more over than it used to be. Right. Well, I mean, did the odds and the newspaper for as long as it was always about that, right? They won't. It's just more overt than it used to be. But, I mean, the, like teams will get fined if they didn't report injuries. Why are they getting fined? Because, right. And it affected the spreads. Then how does it, can you reconcile it with the, with the, with the position that, that baseball took against Pete Rose gambling on, on baseball?
对吧？他们当然想要这样。只不过现在比以前更加明目张胆了而已。对吧？我的意思是，比如报纸上登赔率这种事一直都有，本质上一直都是为了这个，对吧？他们当然想。只不过现在比以前更加明目张胆了。但是，比如球队如果隐瞒伤情会被罚款。他们为什么会被罚款？因为……对啊，因为这会影响到盘口。那么，这怎么能……你该如何解释这种现象，与当年棒球大联盟对皮特·罗斯（Pete Rose）参与棒球赌博采取的严厉立场相调和呢？
And now they're actually a partner of gambling with baseball. No, but, you can't, because the Pete Rose thing, he was betting on his own team. Right. And he was managing that team. So he could affect the outcome. Yeah, and they've been cracking down on, um, they don't want the players to gamble on anything, right? And there's been especially in football. There's been a few guys that got nailed.
而现在，棒球大联盟自己居然成了赌博公司的合作伙伴。不，这两者不能混为一谈，因为皮特·罗斯当年的问题在于，他押注的是自己的球队。而且他当时还是那支球队的主教练。所以他能够操纵比赛结果。对，而且他们现在一直在重拳打击……他们绝对不允许运动员参与任何形式的赌博，对吧？尤其是在橄榄球界，已经有几个家伙因为这个栽了跟头。
But if you go back to the history of the sports, like there's been gambling scandals in every air. But there was a rough basketball ball that just did it, right? Yeah. Oh, yeah. There's been a college basketball in the 50s. There was that huge scandal right at point shaving way back when it was almost killed college basketball. Yeah. The what's weird is there's so much attention on it now. It would be really hard to fix anything. Anytime something's out of whack, everybody, all the casinos, everybody got to know. So they get caught immediately.
但如果你回顾体育史，就会发现在每个时代都有赌博丑闻。比如大学篮球界以前不也干过这种事吗？对啊。哦，是的。50年代的大学篮球界就爆发过那起巨大的操纵比分（point shaving）丑闻，当时差一点就把大学篮球给毁了。对。诡异的是，现在人们对它的关注度太高了，想要在比赛中做点手脚简直难如登天。任何数据一旦出现异常，所有的赌场、所有人都会立刻察觉。所以作弊者会当场被抓个正着。
So yeah, it's part of the dialogue. I just think it's a generational thing. I think for like our kids' generation, they're just more used to hearing the announcers talk about it and the dialogue of these guys were favored by nine. Al Michaels used to be on Sunday night NBC. Great. And he would always be, he would always be discreetly kind of mentioning the line without mentioning
所以，是的，这已经是体育对话的一部分了。我只是觉得这属于代际差异。对于我们孩子那一代人来说，他们从小就习惯了听到解说员谈论这些，习惯了听到“某某队被看好让9分”这样的讨论。以前阿尔·迈克尔斯（Al Michaels）在NBC主持《周日橄榄球之夜》（Sunday Night NBC）时，太棒了。他总是能非常隐蔽地在节目里暗示盘口，却又不明说。
it. Yeah, yeah. He was a big field goal for some people out there. Yeah, exactly. Someone missed an extra point inside the last two minutes. They go, yeah. So now it's just kind of out in the open. Yeah. Yeah. So I'm good just kind of out in the open. Yeah.
对，对。他会说：“对某些人来说，这可是一个价值连城的关键任意球啊。”对，完全是这样。如果在比赛还剩最后两分钟时有人踢丢了一个附加分，他们就会说：“哦，好吧。”所以现在这一切只不过是变得完全公开化了而已。对，对。所以我对此完全能接受。我们马上回来。本节目由 Soylent 提供赞助支持，名字听起来挺搞笑，但营养可是认真的。我们可以拿这个名字开很多玩笑，对吧？
So I'm good with it. We'll be right back. Smartly supported by Soylent, funny name, but serious nutrition, we could come up with lots of jokes on the name, right? But the internet has been there, done that. So we will just focus on how incredible the product is and the science behind it, you it. I'm into science.
但互联网网友们早就把能玩的梗都玩遍了。所以我们还是把重点放在产品本身的惊艳程度以及它背后的科学依据上吧。我是个讲究科学的人。
Soilant was perfected by food scientists and tested by doctors and researchers over the last 10 years. One bottle has all the balanced nutrients of a complete meal, vitamins, minerals, protein, healthy fat, and only one gram of sugar, and it actually tastes great. In fact, at one product of the year, the science-backed food hack is the perfect meal for when you don't want to think about food. Soil and is convenient and requires no refrigeration, so you can have breakfast or lunch whenever and wherever you want or need it. I tried the Soil and Creamy Chocolate Meal replacement shake. That's really good. Of course, I love anything
Soylent 是由食品科学家历经过去10年研发完善、并经过医生和研究人员测试的产品。一瓶就含有完整代餐所需的均衡营养：维生素、矿物质、蛋白质、健康脂肪，而且含糖量仅有一克，关键是味道真的很棒。事实上，它还荣获过年度产品奖。这种以科学为基础的食品黑科技，绝对是当你不想花心思考虑吃什么时的完美代餐。Soylent 非常方便，无需冷藏，所以无论何时何地，只要你需要或想要，随时随地都可以享用早餐或午餐。我尝试了 Soylent 的绵密巧克力味代餐奶昔。真的非常好喝。当然啦，只要是
chocolate. And it was so delicious. And I didn't have to think about meal. I was in and out of my house and my next appointment and no time. Go to Amazon now and get Soil and for 30% off using SmartLess. I repeat, go to Amazon now and get Soil and for 30% off using SmartLess. And back to the show. How are you as a sports gambler? Do you do it? Oh my god. Are you any, you must be good.
巧克力味我都爱。而且味道超级美味。我完全不用为吃什么发愁。从出门办事到赶上下一个预约，我转眼间就搞定了。现在就去亚马逊（Amazon）购买 Soylent，使用优惠码 SmartLess 即可享受七折优惠。我再重复一遍，现在就去亚马逊购买 Soylent，使用优惠码 SmartLess 立享七折优惠。我们言归正传。你作为一个体育赌徒水平怎么样？你平时会下注吗？天哪。你水平……你肯定是个高手吧？
I'm acknowledged. I go up and down. I know you're trying to jinx me right now, but uh-uh. But yeah, we, I have a long history. I started gambling in 1990 because the Patriots went one in 15. And it were only two games on and we were in college and you know, the Patriots were terrible. And it was like this is the worst football season I've ever had.
我有过承认的时候。我也有过起起落落。我知道你现在是想给我“毒奶”一波，但我可不上当。不过，是的，我有一段很长的赌龄。我从1990年开始赌球，因为当时新英格兰爱国者队（Patriots）打出了1胜15负的战绩。当时电视上只有两场比赛可看，我们在上大学，爱国者队又烂得一塌糊涂。那感觉就像是我经历过的最糟糕的一个美式橄榄球赛季。
And you made a million. And we had a buddy on it. Yeah, buddy on my house, I was like, I have a book here. Like what? And we start like betting on football. And all of a sudden I had all these favorite teams. It wasn't just the Patriots. Yeah.
然后你赚了一百万。当时我们宿舍里有个哥们儿……对，我有个室友，他说：“我这里有个地下庄家。”我当时就想：啊？然后我们就开始押注橄榄球。突然之间，我发现自己有了好多支持的球队，再也不仅仅局限于爱国者队了。
So yeah, it's been a long journey. I've written about it a lot. And I've had a lot of fun with it. But now there's like so much analytics and analysis that go with it. Like Sal and I, Jimmy's cousin, Sal, we do a Sunday night podcast on my pod. And we did this over under with win totals last year. And we did great. Like I went like on the win totals, whether a team was going to go over under, I went 24, 7 and 1. It was the best I've ever done. And I was more excited about that than anything.
所以，是的，这是一段漫长的旅程。我写过很多关于这方面的文章，也从中获得了很多乐趣。但现在的体育博彩背后有太多的数据分析和研究了。比如我和萨尔（Sal，吉米·基梅尔的表弟萨尔）每周日在我的播客节目里会固定连线。去年我们预测了各支球队的胜场总数（Win Totals）的超/低盘（Over/Under），结果成绩好得惊人。我的胜场总数预测——也就是预测一支球队最终成绩会高于还是低于盘口——战绩是24胜7负1平。这是我有史以来战绩最好的一次。比起其他任何事，我当时为这个兴奋得不得了。
Over or under a certain number of wins for the year. Yeah, so they'll say like the giants are seven and a half and you're thinking, you're over under. And we just like, and we were like so proud of ourselves that we did well, but there's been other years where we're like, oh my God, we're getting annihilated. Does God hate us? Does that translate to fantasy sports prowess?
也就是预测一支球队一年的胜场数是高于还是低于某个特定数字。对，比如他们会把纽约巨人队（Giants）的胜场线定在7.5场，然后你需要预测是高于还是低于这个数字。我们当时……当发现自己预测得那么准时，简直骄傲得不行。但也有些年份，我们会惨到怀疑人生，心想：天哪，我们简直被血洗了。上帝是不是恨我们？这种神准能转化到梦幻体育（Fantasy Sports）的实力上吗？
Are you really good at that? I was wanting to ask you if you're into fantasy sports. Oh, I was like, I was in the first wave. I was in basketball leagues in the 80s, baseball leagues in 1982. Football since 1990. What's the name of the, wasn't there a baseball group early on in ESPN?
你在梦幻体育方面也很厉害吗？我一直想问你玩不玩梦幻体育。哦，我绝对是第一批尝鲜的人。我80年代就玩篮球梦幻联盟了，1982年开始玩棒球联盟，1990年开始玩橄榄球联盟。那个叫什么来着……ESPN早期不是有个棒球联盟吗？
What was it? Yeah, I wasn't in that, but yeah, it started in the early 80s. There's a bunch of people that have tried to claim they started the first fantasy league and it's, no, but this was like, these guys are like the best supposedly. I forget what it was called, but I wanted to. Well, I'm in the Kimmel League where we vote everybody out and Sal has the hammer this year. And I think he's going gonna vote me out for comedy's sake. Why?
叫什么名字来着？对，我没参加那个，但它确实在80年代初就有了。有一群人都试图宣称自己创立了第一个梦幻联盟，而且……不，但这群人据说全都是顶尖高手。我忘了那叫什么名字了，但我本来想……好吧，我在吉梅尔的联盟里，我们每年都会投票把一个人踢出局，今年萨尔手里握着“生死大权”。我觉得他为了喜剧效果，可能会投票把我投出去。为什么？
Because the trash talks not good enough? Well, we show up and there's 11 owners and only 10 stay and at the beginning of the draft, the guy won the draft the year before votes out one of the 10, one of the other 10. Really? And you just have to get up and get the F out. We had John Ham was in it and he showed up late because he was filming Mad Men. And we waited, waited, waited,
因为你的垃圾话水平不够好？好吧，我们聚在一起时有11个球队老板，但最终只有10个人能留下来。在选秀开始前，去年的选秀冠军要在剩下的10个人里投票淘汰掉其中一个。真的吗？你得当场卷铺盖走人。我们以前有个叫乔恩·哈姆（John Ham）的成员也在里面，他当时因为在拍《广告狂人》（Mad Men）所以迟到了。我们等啊等啊等，
he showed up like a half hour late, comes in, sorry, sorry, it gets a beer, sits down, and then he got voted out and he just struck drank the beer. That's it. Oh my God. I'm the commissioner of my baseball league. It's the worst league in the world
他大概迟到了半小时才进来，一进门就说：“抱歉，抱歉。”然后拿了杯啤酒坐下。结果他立刻就被投票淘汰出局了，他只好把那杯啤酒一口气喝光。就这么被淘汰了。天哪。我是我那个棒球联盟的委员。那是全世界最烂的联盟，
because I don't think that there's not one trash talk at all through the entire season. Yeah, the 90s were so much more fun. Yeah, the 90s people get mad. The draft was like really vicious and then every person nicer. I have a question about this stuff. So what about, you want to focus on the fantasy part of it?
因为整个赛季下来，居然连一句垃圾话都没有。对，90年代可好玩多了。对，90年代的人是真的会生气。当时的选秀过程简直残酷至极，相比之下现在的每个人都太友善了。我有个关于这方面的问题。所以，关于……你想把话题集中在梦幻体育部分吗？
Go ahead. Yeah, exactly. No, why? And I think Jason, well, I think I may have asked this on another episode of our podcast, so we can cut it if so. But if all the smartness available, wherever you get podcasts, mm-hmm, yes, that's smart enough. But you get it early on Wondry without asking.
请继续。对，没错。不，为什么？我觉得杰森……好吧，我想我可能在我们的另一期播客里问过这个问题，如果是的话我们可以剪掉。但是，如果你在所有能收听播客的地方都能听到“聪明脸蛋”（Smartless）——嗯，是的，那就是“聪明脸蛋”。而且你可以在 Wondry 上提前收听，无需额外付费。
If you know, I read about all of these crazy, unbelievably massive amounts of money thrown around to all these players for all these teams, right? Yeah. Just contracts like these guys. So, if these teams and owners and all these people have literally billions of dollars, it seems like why wouldn't they just go by every single top player and have that one team if they have all this money.
如果你知道的话……我看到过所有关于这些疯狂的、难以置信的天价资金在所有这些球员和球队之间流转的新闻，对吧？对。就是那种动辄天价的球员合同。所以，如果这些球队、老板和所有这些相关人员手里掌控着 literalmente（字面意思上）数十亿美元的巨额财富，那看起来……他们为什么不干脆把所有顶尖球员全都买下来，组建一支超级无敌梦幻队呢？既然他们有这么多钱的话。
Bill, you'll be more, you'll be recognized. No, I mean, but there's a, there's an actual, the dadger's kind of tried that. It's working. Well, because they're a, there are rules. There are rules as to how much you, you can actually spend in most roles. Well, there's rules over, over a certain number, you'd think of to start paying a punitive tax on that. But what, how would you explain what's going on with the Yankees and the Red Sox this year
比尔，你来解释会更有权威性。不，我的意思是，这里面有一套……其实道奇队差不多就是这么尝试的。而且还真成功了。好吧，因为这里有规则。关于你到底能在大多数规则下花多少钱，是有明文规定的。对，规则规定一旦超过某个特定数字，你就必须开始为此缴纳惩罚性的奢侈税。但是，你该如何解释今年洋基队和红袜队的现状呢？
with all their payroll? Aren't they the last two in the American league east? The Yankees thing is great. It's, it's, it's, it's, it's hard. The Red Sox cozyed up next to them. The Red Sox aren't winning the title, but what's happened to the Yankees is kind of like my world series of share. It's their fans are so upset. They have Georgetown runners loser Sun Howe runs the team and it's like the classic, like the son who had the only reason he had is the charge of anything. It's just because he was related to his dad, which is always the best and funniest area of sports.
还发着全额工资？他们不是美联东区倒数前两名吗？洋基队这事挺有意思的。这真的很艰难。红袜队跟他们套近乎。红袜队今年又拿不到冠军，但洋基队的遭遇对我来说就像是我自己的世界大赛一样。他们的球迷太沮丧了。老板的儿子——那个一事无成的失败者孙·豪在管理球队，这简直就是个经典案例：儿子之所以能执掌大权，仅仅因为他是他爸的亲生儿子，这永远是体育界最棒、最好笑的领域。
By the way, it's funny thing in any arena, I know this guy. I love the I really on his son running his bed defense. But like think of Hollywood ran this were like Bob Aggers retiring. His son is now the president of Disney. Like it would never happen. And sports, they just hand the teams off. I love kids who are born on third and square on a wild pitch. I love that storyline. It's so great. I'm like, they just have zero talent and yet they're just because their dad had a ton of dough. Bill, you know, you know, well, we were talking about sport. I want to get back to Sean's question, Bill. And, and, and hear what you think about this,
顺便说一句，任何领域里都有这种搞笑的事，我认识这个人。我真的很喜欢他儿子在帮他打理防线。但你想想，如果好莱坞也这样，比如鲍勃·伊格尔退休了，他儿子现在成了迪士尼的总裁。这根本不可能发生。但在体育界，他们直接把球队交接下去。我太喜欢那些生在三垒却以为自己打出三垒安打的人了。我超喜欢这种剧情。太棒了。我就觉得，他们毫无天赋，却仅仅因为他们老爸有很多钱。比尔，你知道的，我们刚才在聊体育。我想回到肖恩的问题，比尔，而且，很想听听你对这件事的看法，
about it. Why can't the owners just go, we were talking about the Red Sox and Yankees. And they, and they do try to do that. And they've had, and you, you're jumping with Glee and how much the Yankees have spent have spent and to no success. Really, what's happening again to bring, I don't want to bring everything back to soccer, but if you look what's happening in the last year in soccer, the Saudis, in fact, the Saudi of sovereign wealth fund, which took control of the top four final clubs, has now provided enough funds for them to go and poach from all the major European leagues, all these top stars and pay them the salaries, Sean.
关于这个。为什么老板们就不能想想，我们刚才在聊红袜队和洋基队。他们也确实在试图这么做。而且，你一直在幸灾乐祸地嘲笑洋基队花巨资却毫无成效。真的，再谈谈——我不想把什么都扯到足球上，但如果你看看过去一年足球界发生的事，沙特人，确切地说，控制了四大决赛俱乐部的沙特主权财富基金，现在为他们提供了足够的资金，让他们去各大欧洲联赛挖角所有这些顶级球星，并支付他们天价薪水，肖恩。
Name our design to $300 million. I know, I'm going to win them all. Plus, they paid a release clause of 80 million euros to PSG. They apparently offered in Bapet 750 million euros to play for one year. Yeah, I remember. Ronaldo's getting 400 a year. I mean, this is, they're doing that exact thing that you're talking about.
比如给我们开出三亿美元的报价。我知道，我恨不得把他们全签下。另外，他们还向巴黎圣日耳曼支付了8000万欧元的解约金。据说他们还给姆巴佩开出了7.5亿欧元的年薪让他踢一年。对，我记得。罗纳尔多的年薪是4亿。我的意思是，他们正在做你刚才说的那种事。
Bill, what do you think that something like that does to the balance of world sport? Well, soccer, it's just basically a free market and they're all maniacs. I think the NBA had a little bit of this issue where they had this luxury tax and it was punitive, but then you had a team like the Warriors that were saying, we'll screw it. You know, we're in San Francisco, we make a shitload of money, we want to win the title
比尔，你觉得这种事对世界体育的平衡会产生什么影响？嗯，足球基本上就是一个自由市场，那些家伙全都是狂人。我觉得NBA也有点类似的问题，他们有奢侈税，而且惩罚力度很大，但随后你就会遇到像勇士队这样的球队，他们会说：“去他的吧。你知道的，我们在旧金山，我们赚海了钱，我们就想拿总冠军。”
over here and they had like a three, with the tax, they paid like 350 million for last year's team. So in the new collective bargaining agreement, they changed it so that, all right, if you go over this number, not only is there a tax, but now you're gonna have your issues with your draft picks, issues with how you feel at your roster, you're not gonna be able to do trades as easily. Oh, really?
他们这边，算上奢侈税，去年的阵容花了大概3.5亿美元。所以在新的劳资协议中，他们改变了规则：好吧，如果你超过这个数字，不仅要交税，你的选秀权还会受影响，阵容构建也会受限，你将无法那么轻松地完成交易。哦，真的吗？
And they really made it harder. And now, but what's funny is, there's always some new owner, it's always a rich guy, they come in, like obviously rich guy, they own the team new owner. It's always a rich guy. They come in like obviously rich guy. They own the team, but like some newer way of rich guys. So the guy about Phoenix, this guy Matt Ishbeer, who I actually kind of like, he's a fun character. Yeah, I kind of like him too.
而且他们真的把难度加大了。现在，但有趣的是，总会有一些新老板，全都是有钱人，他们入场了，显然是个有钱人，他们买下了球队，成了新老板。总是个有钱人。他们入场了，显然是个有钱人。他们买下了球队，但属于一种更新潮的有钱人。就像菲尼克斯的那个老板，这个叫马特·伊斯比亚的家伙，我其实还挺喜欢他的，他是个挺有意思的人物。对，我也挺喜欢他的。
But he came in and he's just like, they all want a zag, right? They're like, everybody's going this way. I'm gonna zag. And he's like, we don't care about draft picks. We're gonna pay for Kevin Durant. We, they traded for Bradley Beale. We're gonna pay for Kevin Durant. They traded for Bradley Beale. We're gonna have this crazy payroll. And like, everybody else is afraid of luxury techs.
但他一进来就觉得，所有人都想跟风，对吧？他们就觉得：“所有人都在走这条路，我要反其道而行之。”他就说：“我们不在乎选秀权。我们要花钱签下凯文·杜兰特。我们，他们交易来了布拉德利·比尔。我们要花钱签下凯文·杜兰特。”他们交易来了布拉德利·比尔。“我们要打造这种疯狂的薪资结构。”就像，其他人都在害怕奢侈税。
I'm not afraid. And those are always my favorite owners. Like Brooklyn got bought by this Russian guy, Prokerov, and the early 2010s. And he's like, I'm gonna spend and just made all these crazy moves. And then two years later, he's like, eh, I don't want to do this anymore. And then just stop spending money and the Celtics had all their draft picks.
我不怕。而这些永远是我最喜欢的球队老板。比如布鲁克林在2010年代初被这个俄罗斯人普罗霍罗夫买下，他当时就说：“我要疯狂花钱，”然后做出了所有这些疯狂的运作。结果两年后，他却说：“呃，我不想再这么搞了。”然后就停止花钱了，而凯尔特人却拥有他们所有的选秀权。
So the whims of these guys that they, you know, they see these teams as like these toys and these things to play with. Yeah, yeah, yeah. But meanwhile, all these, you know, hundreds of thousands of fans are attached to the team. Yeah. And these guys can just run rough shot, which is what's happened with the Yankees now. It's owned by the owner, the dead owner's son, and he just won't fire anybody and they're in chaos.
所以这些家伙的任性就在于，你知道的，他们把这些球队看作是他们的玩具和消遣的东西。对，对，对。但与此同时，所有这些，你知道的，几十万的球迷都对球队倾注了感情。对。而这些家伙却可以为所欲为，就像现在洋基队发生的情况一样。它被前老板的儿子买下了，而他就是不肯解雇任何人，现在一团糟。
Well, it occurs to me that there's, that you can almost draw a parallel between that and maybe any business, but certainly our business that, that you have these big sort of rich guys who either rich themselves or control these big corporations, they're driven by whatever stock price, et cetera. And there's no actual reverence for the thing itself, right? So they're culturally, they don't really care about what impact. So they come and they go, I'm gonna buy this team. Well, hey, look, it's really bad for basketball
嗯，我突然想到，你可以把这与某种现象画上等号，也许是任何商业，但绝对是我们的商业，那就是你拥有这些身家巨富的家伙，他们要么自己很有钱，要么掌控着这些大公司，他们被股票价格等因素驱动。对这事物本身并没有真正的敬畏，对吧？所以在文化上，他们根本不在乎会产生什么影响。所以他们走过来，说：“我要买下这支球队。”好吧，嘿，听着，这对篮球来说真的很糟糕
or it's really bad for soccer. And they're like, I don't give a shit. I'm gonna be dead in 15 years. I just wanna win a couple of championship and I'm gonna give a shit. And that's happening in entertainment 15 years. I just wanna win a couple of championship and I don't give a shit. And that's happening in entertainment. These guys came in, these people came in, they run it, and they're like potentially destroying it.
或者对足球真的很糟糕。而他们却说：“我他妈才不在乎。我15年后都要入土了。我只想赢几个总冠军，我才不在乎别的。”娱乐界也正在发生这种事。15年后。我只想赢几个总冠军，我才不在乎。娱乐界也正在发生这种事。这些家伙进来了，这些人进来了，他们接管了球队，并且有可能将其毁掉。
And they're like, I don't give a shit. I just wanna strip it down and sell the pieces off. And I don't give a fuck of it, you know, fucks culturally with this, you know, this thing. Is this why Dr. Pimple Poppers on the lead cover of Max right now? Is that a succession or a curvent? Yeah, that's exactly why.
而他们的态度是：“我他妈才不在乎。我只想把它拆得七零八落，把零件全卖掉。我才不管这会不会在文化上把这玩意儿给毁了呢。”这就是为什么挤痘医生现在能上《Maxim》杂志的封面吗？这是《继承之战》的剧情还是现实？对，这正是原因所在。
Hey, Bill, do you think that the fan base to your point about how all these hundreds of thousand people are associated and attached to each team in the fan base? Yeah. Does the fan base really have any leverage? Like if an owner is just in a tailspin, can they strike effectively and say more or not with the Washington football fans. They had this owner who was Daniel Snyder who was like the worst owner. He was like the championship belt holder every year.
嘿，比尔，你觉得球迷群体——正如你所说，这几十万人如何与每支球队以及球迷群体息息相关——对吧？球迷群体真的有什么话语权吗？比如如果一个老板把球队搞得一团糟，他们能有效地发起罢看，并表示“再也不去了”吗？就像华盛顿橄榄球队的球迷那样。他们曾有过这样一个老板丹尼尔·斯奈德，他简直就是最烂的老板。他每年都稳拿最烂老板金腰带。
And he sucked the life out of the franchise and the city to the point that, you know, they would have a home game and they'd have more fans of the other team and everybody was like, I'm out until this guy's gone. And it really had no impact on him. It's the TV rights that really have the left. And financially, they still sold for how many billion. Right. Well, what happened was the sponsors started fleeing and it became, and then he had a couple
他榨干了这支球队和这座城市的生机，以至于你知道的，他们打主场比赛时，客队球迷比主队还多，所有人都觉得：“只要这家伙还在，我就再也不看了。”但这对他其实没有任何影响。真正有话语权的是电视转播权。而且从财务上讲，球队最终还是卖了不知多少个亿。好吧，真正发生的情况是赞助商开始逃离，事情开始发酵，然后他又摊上了好几件
other things. But that's because of his behavior personally. And his behavior wasn't great. And his behavior wasn't great. But that's the thing. These guys, like the Phoenix Sunzoner had this whole toxic environment and they made himself. And then he sells, and he sells for like a record price, you know.
其他的事情。但那是因为他个人的行为。而且他的行为确实不怎么样。而且他的行为确实不怎么样。但关键就在这里。这些家伙，比如菲尼克斯太阳队的老板，搞出了整个有毒的氛围，是他自己作出来的。然后他转手卖掉，而且卖出了创纪录的高价，你知道的。
So we're stirling. We're stirling made a bunch of people. Stirling is the same thing, right? Right, Stirling's the worst guy probably has ever owned a team. And you know, he cashed out and made more money than anybody else. By the way, my feeling on that, I've thought about it since that sale and that everything that went down. And then his family was trying to block him from selling it to Steve Balmer back in the
斯特林也是。斯特林让好多人赚了钱。斯特林也是一样，对吧？没错，斯特林可能是所有拥有过球队的最烂的家伙。你知道的，他套现了，赚得比谁都多。顺便说一句，我对这件事的感受是，自从那次出售以及随之发生的一切之后，我就一直在思考。当时他的家族试图阻止他把球队卖给史蒂夫·鲍尔默，
day. And then they were claiming that he was sort of unfit to make the deal sterling himself and all this stuff. And I think it was all by design to drive the price up. Now I'm, I'm acidic, but I do think that that was all by design because the more that they, the family was fighting and they were saying, the price just kept going up just to grab it. Oh, no question.
然后他们声称斯特林本人已经不适合进行这笔交易之类的。我觉得这一切都是为了推高价格而精心设计的。现在，我是个阴谋论者，但我确实认为那一切都是设计好的，因为他们家族闹得越凶，他们说的那些话，价格就越炒越高，纯粹是为了捞钱。哦，毫无疑问。
I have had clippers season tickets for 20 years because I got him to go see the other teams. And so, but I got to know a lot of the people in my section and Sterling would show up and he'd be dressed in all black and he'd sit court side. And it was he was like the fucking grim reaper. And he would go and you know, this team had such a malaise
我买快船队的季票已经20年了，因为我买季票是为了去看别的球队。所以，我认识了我们那个区的好多球迷，而斯特林有时会现身，他全身穿得黑乎乎的，坐在场边。他就像他妈的死神一样。他会走过来，你知道的，这支球队当时弥漫着一种死气沉沉的气氛
and then you have the lakers on the other side that are like one of the jewels of the league. And it was like a fascinating sociology experiment to watch this fan base. Who basically their hope was either he's gonna sell or they're gonna stumble into some draft pick that will get them LeBron. But if neither of those things happen,
然后你看看湖人队，他们在另一边就像是联盟的明珠之一。看着这群球迷的心态，真是一场迷人的社会学实验。他们的希望基本上要么是他卖掉球队，要么是他们能瞎猫碰死耗子抽到一个能把勒布朗带给他们的选秀权。但如果这两件事都没发生，
I'm here to see the other teams, and that was kind of the vibe. So Bill, not to embarrass you, but you've done very, very well financially with all of your ass. So of your ass. Well, not like you. But you're a junior.
我就是来看其他球队的，当时差不多就是这种氛围。所以，比尔，不是要让你难堪，但你所有的资产——呃，你的资产——在财务上做得非常非常成功。好吧，不像你。但你是个后起之秀。
And we're trying. But you're crushing it. My question is, as you mentioned, courtside seats, what's the thing that you could never afford that once you started really doing well, you treated yourself to, it doesn't have to be sports based. I can guess one thing, because you're living in Wayne Manor. It looks like. Yeah, it looks like an IWane Manor.
我们在努力。但你太成功了。我的问题是，正如你提到的场边座位，有什么东西是你以前绝对买不起的，一旦你真正成功了，你就用来犒劳自己，这不一定非得是体育相关的。我能猜到一样东西，因为你住在韦恩庄园里。看起来是这样的。对，看起来像韦恩庄园。
But because you see them, you've really kept very close contact with your sort of simpler self, you know, and I don't mean that it's a pejorative, but you're a very normal guy, which is great. So, thanks Jason. So, how are you, does it, is it comfortable to say, well, you know, you're not, you're a very, you're a mogul, but you don't seem like one. You're in a t-shirt and you're just talking with the us idiots.
但因为你见过世面，你却依然跟自己比较朴实的本色保持着非常紧密的联系，你知道的，我这绝不是贬义，你是个非常普通的人，这真的很棒。所以，谢谢你，杰森。那么，你是怎么看待……说出来会让你觉得自在吗？好吧，你知道的，你不是——你是个大亨，但你看起来一点也不像。你穿着T恤，就在跟我们这群白痴聊天。
And so how are you able to match all of your dreams? All of the, yeah, all your dreams with trying to stay grounded. I've never, well, just on the courtside seats thing. Yeah. They're actually like, it's like a pretty bad seat. Have you ever put their expensive? Like if you're in a basketball game, I'm always like amazed people spend that amount of money.
所以你是如何将你的所有梦想——所有的，是的，所有的梦想——与努力保持脚踏实地结合在一起的？我从来没……好吧，就拿场边座位这事来说吧。实际上，那里的座位挺糟糕的。你有坐过吗？很贵的好吧。如果你去看篮球比赛，我总是对人们花那么多钱买那样的座位感到震惊。
I think it's really just to be kind of seen on the court. Right. But you're too close. Like the seats I have for the corporate games were like four or five rows up. Same for my dad, Celtic tickets that he's had for like 52 years. There's perspective and you can actually watch it. The courts I think, like sitting front row in a movie theater. I always say that about hockey games, people who are like, I'm going to write down in
我觉得那纯粹是为了在球场上露个脸，对吧。但你坐得太近了。比如我为公司比赛买的座位大概在四五排左右。我爸买的凯尔特人门票也是这样，他已经买52年了。这样才有视角，你才能真正看清比赛。场边座位，就像坐在电影院的第一排看电影一样。我每次评价冰球比赛时都这么说，那些坐在玻璃墙边的人，
the glass. I'm like, great, you got the worst seats in the house. You can't see shit. You want to be hockey, you want to be 10, 15 rows up the space between the red lines. Or right between, right behind the goalie is cool because we had those king seats for a couple years. Oh, that's cool too. Yeah. That's where you're like, how is every goalie not just completely traumatized in a mental hospital? When you see what happens to them, narrow lives, it's just like they're
我说：“太棒了，你买到了全场最烂的座位。你什么也看不清。”你想看冰球，你想坐在红线之间的10到15排。或者正对着、正紧挨着守门员后面也很酷，因为我们当过几年国王队的包厢票。哦，那也很酷。对。坐在那儿你会想：怎么每个守门员没有全都被整得精神崩溃送进疯人院？当你看到他们遭遇的一切，他们朝不保夕的生活，简直就是
getting just things fired at them. There's all this commotion in front of them. They're falling, they're jumping up, they're falling, and you're like, how has any of these guys? They are. Health it. Yeah. That's a straight jacket. Bill, what do you do when you're not, how is any of these guys? They are. Health it. Yeah. That's a straight jacket. Bill, what do you do when you're not watching sports? What's your thing? This is sort of a Jason Bateman question. What's the thing?
各种东西朝他们砸过来。他们前面一片混乱。他们摔倒，跳起来，又摔倒，你会觉得：这些家伙怎么可能撑下来？他们确实撑下来了。健康状况堪忧。对。那简直就是个紧身疯人衣。比尔，当你不在——怎么会有人撑得下来？他们确实撑下来了。健康状况堪忧。对。那简直就是个紧身疯人衣。比尔，当你不在看体育比赛时，你会做什么？你喜欢干什么？这有点像杰森·贝特曼会问的问题。你喜欢干什么？
What's your, what's your, what's your, your guilty pleasure? Yeah, your guilty pleasure that you watch or you do or you read or something that's outside of the realm of what you do professionally? Well, oh, outside because it's a lot of sports movies and TV and I host this rewatchables podcast where We do a podcast about a movie every week that people really like and it's fun to like try to figure out Is that rewatchables worthy or not and then if it is I'll watch it twice But what is there something else that you do that's outside of that or no? You mean just like my personal stuff. Yeah, your personal stuff. I have yeah, I have two kids
你的，你的，你的——你的罪恶之乐是什么？对，你平时会看、会做、会读的，或者超出你职业范围之外的罪恶之乐是什么？嗯，哦，超出范围，因为我看了很多体育电影和电视节目，而且我主持了一个名为《重温俱乐部》的播客，我们每周都会做一期关于一部大家都很喜欢的电影的播客，去琢磨这部电影值不值得重温，如果值得的话，我会看两遍。但除此之外，你还有什么别的消遣吗？还是没有？你是说我个人的私生活吗？对，你的私生活。我有，我有两个孩子。
A lot of kids sports both of my kids are athletes. What do they play? My son is football on the cross. My daughter is playing soccer action in college right now. So, so I had a lot of, there's a lot of sports parent stuff that kind of took over and they, you know, still playing tennis and still a lot of like stuff with the friends. You know, you find your little friend group
有很多儿童体育活动，我的两个孩子都是运动员。他们练什么项目？我儿子练橄榄球和长曲棍球。我女儿现在在大学校队踢足球。所以，有很多体育家长的事务占据了我的时间，而且他们，你知道的，我还在打网球，还有很多和朋友聚会的事情。随着年纪增长，
as you get older and you do the dinners and then somebody gets mad at somebody and you talk about it the next day. It's great. Yeah. Well, we can't believe we had you long ago. We can talk to you forever. Yeah.
你会找到自己的小社交圈，一起吃晚餐，然后有人对某人生气了，第二天大家拿出来讨论一番。这感觉很棒。对。好吧，我们真不敢相信这么早就把你请来了。我们可以跟你聊上一整天。对。
You're the man. Yeah. Thank you for doing this again. Thank you guys. I can't wait for you guys not to run this. Yeah, we promised to air this one. Promise. And go socks until the, until the world's I can't wait for you guys not to run this. Yeah, we promised to air this one. Promise.
你太棒了。谢谢你再次来参加我们的节目。谢谢你们，伙计们。我已经等不及看你们把这期节目剪掉了。对，我们答应过会播出这一期的。保证。在世界大赛开始前，支持红袜队。我已经等不及看你们把这期节目剪掉了。对，我们答应过会播出这一期的。保证。
And go socks until the, until the World Series. And we'll let the Dodgers play. I agree. Go socks. We won't be in the World Series. Don't worry. I'll give you the red socks. Celtics. You can have. Yeah. And by the way, guys, it's, it was cool to be on the test show and then watch how the podcast bossen.
在世界大赛开始前，支持红袜队。我们还是让道奇队去打吧。我同意。支持红袜队。我们进不了世界大赛的，别担心。红袜队归你了。凯尔特人队你可以拿去。对。顺便说一句，伙计们，能去那个脱口秀节目，然后看着这个播客节目不断壮大，这感觉真的很酷。
I remember telling Bateman, I was like, do you want to guess what I'm doing? So it's modified, I was like, no, I think we're gonna hold on to this. We kind of like just kind of being in control of it. And it turned out to be very smart. Well, we'll see. But we're certainly having a lot of fun.
我记得我告诉过贝特曼，我说：“你想猜猜我在做什么吗？”所以稍微调整了一下，我说：“不，我觉得我们还是自己留着吧。我们挺喜欢把主控权掌握在自己手里的。”结果证明这非常聪明。好吧，我们走着瞧。但我们确实玩得很开心。
We're in the bed on our bed on ourselves. I know it's true. Thank you for making the bed that we're enjoying, resting and. Yeah. I think you're gonna be a good ass. Thank you for making the bed that we're enjoying. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Thank you to you to Paul. Thanks, Bill. See you, man. Bye, buddy. Well, that is a, that's a good man for coming back. Yeah. I was so long ago. I didn't remember anything we talked about. So it was, it was three, it was well over three years ago that we first had him on it was one of our first shows and we Asked him about the podcast business because we know if you can imagine that we've been
我们押注在自己身上。我知道这是真的。谢谢你们铺好了这张让我们能舒舒服服躺在上面的床。对。我觉得你会成为一个很好的嘉宾。谢谢你们铺好了这张让我们能舒舒服服躺在上面的床。对。对。对。也谢谢保罗。谢谢你，比尔。再见，伙计。拜拜，老兄。好吧，这真是个肯赏脸回来的好人。对。那是好久以前的事了。我都记不清我们聊过什么了。所以，我们第一次邀请他上节目已经是三年多前的事了，那是我们的早期节目之一，我们
First, right? Yes, actually, first, first, first, first, first But and then we got very topical at the time and so yeah, just didn't work and I'm Jason's Kudos to you for bringing him back and see such a I love that interesting guy. I could talk to Forever about everything. I really admire there's been able to just crush it in multiple areas and. I know, how about we, you just stay for granted?
当时就问过他关于播客生意的事，因为我们知道，如果你能想象得到，我们当时——首先，对吧？是的，事实上，是第一，第一，第一，第一，但后来我们当时聊了很多时事话题，所以，是的，效果不太好。杰森，真得感谢你把他请回来，他真的是一个——我太喜欢这个有趣的人了。我可以跟他聊一整天各种话题。我真的很钦佩他能在多个领域都取得巨大成功。
A topic up and he fucking knows about it. It's crazy. Yeah, yeah, you don't want to get into an argument with him. He'll kill you in fact. So who's thinking? How's the by-work coming? Yeah, Sean, how is the by-work coming? Well, I can't really, you're glates.
我知道，你随便抛出一个话题，他妈的他全都知道。太疯狂了。对，对，你可千万别想跟他争论。事实上他能把你驳得体无完肤。那么，谁在思考？打广告这事进展得怎么样了？对，肖恩，打广告这事进展得怎么样了？好吧，我真的不能——你那副墨镜。
I know you've been working on it for probably 40 minutes. You're wearing, oh, you're not wearing your regular glasses, you're wearing your, bye. Bye. Oh, balls. With the astros from Arnett. Bye. Until your day.
我知道你大概戴着它工作了40分钟了。你戴着——哦，你戴的不是普通的眼镜，你戴的是你的——拜拜。哦，见鬼。来自阿奈特的宇航员眼镜。拜拜。祝你今天过得愉快。
A smart. Smartness is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armjurf, Bennett Barbaco and Michael Granterry. Smart, less. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon music, or early and add free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondry app. Smilest is full of celebrity guests and laughs, but if you want something more airy, try the new podcast Go Story about my investigation into a murder suicide in my own family. Go SoundReal, at least that's what I've always believed. Sure, odd things happen in my childhood bedroom, but ultimately I shrubged it all off. That is, until a couple of years ago, when I discovered that every subsequent occupant of that house is convinced they've experienced something inexplicable too, including the
SmartLess由罗布·阿姆杰夫、贝内特·巴尔巴科和迈克尔·格兰特里100%有机手工打造。SmartLess。我们的下一期节目将在下周发布，你可以在任何收听播客的地方收听，也可以现在就在亚马逊音乐上抢先收听，或者通过订阅苹果播客或Wondry App上的Wondry Plus抢先收听并享受无广告体验。SmartLess充满了名人的欢声笑语，但如果你想听点更诡异的，试试新播客《幽灵故事》，讲述我对家族中一起谋杀自杀案的调查。去听听《幽灵故事》吧，至少我一直是这么认为的。当然，我童年的卧室里确实发生过一些奇怪的事情，但最终我都将其抛诸脑后。直到几年前，我发现这栋房子的每一位后来的住户都坚信他们也经历了一些无法解释的事情，包括
most recent inhabitant who says she was visited at night by the ghost of a faceless woman. It just so happens that the alleged ghost haunted my childhood room might just be my wife's great grandmother. It was murdered in the house next door by two gunshots to the face. Ghost Story, a podcast about family secrets, overwhelming coincidence, and the things that come back to haunt us. Follow Ghost Story wherever you get your podcasts. Listen everywhere on October 23rd or you can binge early and ad free on Wondry Plus the same day.
最近的一位住户，她说她夜里曾被一个无脸女人的幽灵拜访过。碰巧的是，那个据称闹鬼的幽灵——我童年卧室里的幽灵，很可能就是我妻子的曾祖母。她是在隔壁房子里被两枪击中面部谋杀的。\\《幽灵故事》\\，一部关于家族秘密、压倒性巧合以及那些回来纠缠我们的事物的播客。在各大播客平台搜索并订阅《幽灵故事》。10月23日全网开播，你也可以在同一天在Wondry Plus上抢先畅听无广告版。
plus the same day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在同一天。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。